when you're arguing a point using logic
you establish premises to support a
conclusion but many times your
conclusion doesn't actually follow from
your line of reasoning no matter how
much you or your opponent are convinced
by your argument in that case you may be
relying on a fallacy to persuade
yourself in your opponent this word
fallacy sounds charged and can certainly
get tossed from side to side and hated
debates but in logic of fallacy is
merely a descriptive term and says
nothing about how dumb you are nor about
whether or not there exists some real
way to support the same conclusion let
me show you how it works
I made an argument in the previous video
demonstrating that coffee isn't a
beverage but a food in this argument I
relied on two distinct meanings of the
word coffee and two different meanings
of the word beans in my premises I was
intentionally vague and used compact
language to hide these choices this
simple language makes the argument much
more convincing than if I disclose the
intended meaning of these words
the result the conclusion looks like it
follows from the premises but it's
really not supported by them the
conclusion may or may not be true but
it's uncalled for here this reliance on
the psychological persuasiveness of a
statement is a hallmark feature of
informal fallacies which are informal
because the truthfulness of the
conclusions content can't be derived
from the truthfulness of the content of
the premises still the arguments for may
be perfectly valid like my food is
coffee syllogism here are some examples
of informal fallacies
and the list goes on in all cases
informal fallacies rely on content that
does something other than support the
conclusion in order to get you to accept
the conclusion you can get a feel for
how the logic of the supporting line of
reasoning actually runs if you just
remove the fallacious statement like
this not so reasonable now is it recall
that arguments don't just have content
they also have form we called an
argument with well-structured premises
and a conclusion valid so it may not
surprise you to hear of formal fallacies
which arise when we shape the argument
in a way that the conclusion doesn't
follow from the premises but people can
still be persuaded by the conclusion
because it seems to follow let's play
around with a few arguments to see if
you can spot weaknesses in their form in
their structure first a refresher a
basic syllogism a is B B is C so a is C
fill it in as you like we've seen that
this form works next a second point of
reference and an even simpler argument
if P then Q P therefore Q this is a
basic reasoning strategy and it works
what about this one a is not B B is not
C therefore a is C think about it for a
moment and check against other examples
if you need to the first premise only
supports that a is not B so anything we
say about B in the second premise can't
apply to a positively or negatively the
conclusion doesn't follow this next one
runs aground on the same issue as the
last a is not B so no matter what we say
about B it doesn't apply to a
what's wrong here I've negated P in this
conditional statement then assume that Q
must also be negated but perhaps Q is
conditioned on something else
spot the problem here yet no look closer
keep looking because you won't find it
this one's good and I leave it to you
and your clever ways to figure out why
one more for you can I argue that what
follows from a conditional implies what
precedes consider this form carefully a
implies B only states that if a holds B
also holds it does not mean that B
always follows from a come on you
remember your logical by conditionals
right that's all for fallacies well for
this introduction of fallacies I'm sure
you'll encounter plenty more these last
two topics introduced arguments and
fallacies and I'll add them to my
playlist for the internal logic if
you're visiting a youtube channel and to
the lesson page on native blank com I
hope you've enjoyed a bit more logic
than that thanks for learning with me